we in our lives can be whoever we want
to create ourselves to be there's
nothing wrong with that at all it's
awesome to do that
action's been called in life one time
the day we were born and Cut's going to
be called one time when they leave this
life so what are we doing the camera's
been rolling yeah history will tell the
story yeah our story will be there you
know so and it's live we're in it we're
living it right now so what are we doing
who are we going to be
quicker we are faced with a struggle or
a problem that we need to solve
the quicker we go all right is this real
yep it's real all right what am I going
to do about this yeah instead of going I
can't whose fault it is why me is this
really real it's real again it's real
again tomorrow it's really good then
it's been real for a day it's been real
for a week it's been you it's been real
for a year it's been real for a decade
yeah it's been real my whole life the
quicker we go no it's real
let's get on with keeping our eyes open
for Solutions how can I sometimes how
can I out hustle this situation uh
sometimes cat can I out endure this
situation sometimes it's need to Pivot
need to change the old aperture chain
lens is on the way I'm looking at this
position I've been banging my head on
this door only to find out that if I
backed up 10 feet I could see there's uh
there's a opening over there and I can
walk around the damn door yeah and then
sometimes we got to just go man I'm
banging my head on this thing my head's
bruised and bloody and I've looked all
around it from every angle I don't see a
solution I raise the White Flag I'll
fight another look at it you got that
one I'm gonna spend some more time on
some other problem
and I don't know what success is but I
know what failure is it's trying to
please everybody yes let's just look at
that as a mean of life right now be
surprised not it happens it's not a debt
don't look at it's like a debit
now the ruining would be a debit but
that's just us exaggerating the tragedy
that doesn't happen so usually what we
think is going to be ruined is basically
just a rejection yeah and a rejection is
we're looking at it either I'm going oh
this is part of life I look I suffer
from this when things are going well and
I'm getting what I want and I'm
succeeding I have a tendency to think
this
is how life is supposed this is the mean
no it's not enjoyed that up there so
when I talk about the art of running
downhill you're running downhill bro
don't trip yourself because if the
incline's coming it uphill will come yes
so don't think that this is just the
mean because if you think that when
everything's going perfectly like ta-da
I got it I found my frequency it's so
easy I'll never get in a rut again
false
and then when you do you think oh I
failed I'm ruined you're like no you
were exaggerating the the realities of
life you were you were living like he
was happy yeah you were living in heaven
on Earth but that wasn't
sustainable forever right
about thousands of Crisis is in my life
and
most stuff never happened most midlife
crisis
are more about not appreciating where
we've been yeah maybe not appreciating
giving respect to what we have done or
what we already have built so I got a
tend to those things no matter what New
Horizon I'm chasing or new place I'm
going I've got some stuff going with me
my family my kids this part of my career
that's not negotiable so even though I
may be uncertain of where I'm going in
the future I got some baggage I got some
luggage that's going with me yeah no
matter what and that's giving respect to
those things I think that's where a lot
of us
get any
crisis sometimes in a typical midlife
crisis we don't respect what we've done
and what we've built and appreciate
where we've been maybe enough sometimes
it's just more important to make the
damn choice that was the whole commit to
it and go for it and find out so you
don't find yourself after three years of
limbo we've been in four years five
years six years a decade of limbo and
you look back and you go oh I'm still
walking to Tyro yeah why didn't I just
jump because what happens when we what
happens when we jump and just make a
choice if we fail it very seldom hurts
as much as we thought absolutely and we
don't have any regrets about the choice
found out and and all the people that
went nah nana boo boo you didn't want
them being in your life anyway your
story you know what I mean so good we
Define them you know but the people that
when you fail after you make a choice to
come over and go hey man me too and the
same thing you're like hey
found a good friend he found a good
soldier you found a good acquaintance
you found somebody that's on your side
that's the people you want in your life
anyway we all want to figure out who we
are hey everyone's their own creation
just create it we all want to know what
that is
be affirmative
way to go forward how to play offense
what I found that
and I think the reasonable first step to
figuring out who we are is let's
Define who we're not
let's pick out those people places
things we do habits we have that don't
pay us back that don't feed us tomorrow
that that don't that don't give us green
lights in the future those Investments
that don't have Roi those ones that we
keep waking up tomorrow and a little bit
of a debit damn it I got a hangover
I had the same amount of drinks at that
bar as I have somewhere else but I got a
worse hangover well maybe it's the
conversation people were hanging out
with eliminate those
and by process of elimination sheer
mathematics you'd end up with more room
for the things that do feed you so it's
a much easier thing to start pointing
out ah you know what I keep doing that
and it doesn't pay me back now I'm not
getting my compounding asset on that
decision or those people placing to
eliminate those and by sheer mathematics
we end up with more of what does feed us
and pay us back who we are investments
that we make choices we make
I noticed in in writing the book that a
lot of successes I had were engineered
by habits and choices I made that had
consistency that's what I call it a
science dissatisfaction I believe there
is a science to satisfaction I noticed
what I was eating who I was hanging out
with when I was going to bed and what I
how I was approaching the day
there were consistencies that led to
times my life where I had more joy and
more success was catching more green
lights I also noticed times where I was
in a rut
through my journals of oh you veered
from these tried and true habits that
you had that were leading to success and
giving you more green lights oh let's
get back in our lane over here and sure
enough
more success in green lights I started
to create for myself
good man that's the sacrifice and things
has to take some risks and take some
responsibilities and follow through on
them and know it may not be popular but
is it popular in his soul at 2 A.M alone
in his bed
and does he have do we have the courage
to take that into the daylight do we
have the courage to go I know that's
true I'm gonna be and I know this is I
know this is true I will follow up on
this in the face of the adversity
um a good man doesn't go look into
trouble everything does cost us
something
and I think a good man a good woman
will put their ass in line for the cost
and it's worth more
the credit or the debit the winner those
it's worth more that currency is worth
more